ils sont d'ailleurs 11 11 en course dans
cette 11e circonscription des yvelines
vous voyez leur nom s'afficher premier
tour le dimanche 20 septembre une
élection rendue nécessaire pour à peine
après la démission de nadia est devenu
ministre délégué à la ville dans le
nouveau gouvernement
et parmi les candidats l'un d'entre eux
est avec moi patrick lang bonsoir vous
êtes cheminots ouvriers de maintenance à
la sncf à la gare de triage de trappes
vous êtes candidat de lutte ouvrière
dans cette 11e circonscription vous
l'étiez déjà comme suppléant en 2017 est
derrière christine & gas là c'est elle
qui est votre suppléante et vous avez
obtenu 3 % lors des élections
municipales à trappes où vous étiez
également candidat en mars dernier
pourquoi cette nouvelle candidature
pourquoi finalement continuer votre
engagement qui n'est pas nouveau du
collège parce que de toute façon les
problèmes restent les mêmes la situation
pour les travailleurs elle s'est même
aggravée avec la crise économique la
crise du coc vide et on est très loin de
trouver des solutions pour les
travailleurs aujourd'hui et donc notre
candidature puisqu'il y en a d'autres
dans d'autres circonscriptions elles
sont tout à fait justifiées faire
entendre la voix des travailleurs c'est
l'objectif de votre candidature et vous
le disais c'est d'autant plus important
est que ce contexte de crise sanitaire
qui s'est muée en crise économique avec
des chiffres du chômage qui ne sont pas
bons alors là c'est quand même mieux
les chiffres du chômage sont
catastrophiques et ils vont encore être
catastrophique ils vont continuer et
c'est loin d'être suffisant le plan de
relance que le gouvernement a proposé
ces dernières semaines 100 milliards
distribués à fonds perdus aux
entreprises
c'est inadmissible dans le sens où les
grandes entreprises qui vont bénéficier
de cette aide de ces aides publiques
ils vont continuer à faire des plans de
licenciements continuer à faire des
plans de suppressions d'emplois et
résiste pour puisqu'on parle du chômage
parce qu'il faut les mettre là en face
de l'autre 100 milliards ces 2,7
millions
d'emploi qu'on pourrait créer
directement à 1800 euros net par mois
c'est là la solution réellement pour
pour si on veut régler le problème du
chômage si on veut régler le problème de
la répartition du travail entre tous et
c'est ça se peut être être une mesure à
porter à l'assemblée nationale quels
sont les autres je crois que parmi les
propositions celle d'interdire les
licenciements notamment bien sûr parce
que quand on voit aujourd'hui aussi bien
une boîte de l'aéronautique airbus
thales pour palais pas les nommer
nokia et nokia et alinéa
bien sûr qu'on est scandalisé par par
ces plans de licenciements au parfum bon
voilà ces grands groupes qui ont fait
des bénéfices depuis des années des
années depuis des dizaines d'années qui
ont engrangé des fortunes colossales et
qui aujourd'hui sous prétexte de
difficultés pas avérée font pression sur
les travailleurs licenciés etc
oui ça c'est inadmissible mais j'imagine
qui est aussi un intérêt particulier
avec cette rentrée à l'assemblée
nationale un sujet qui va revenir sur la
table celui de la réforme des retraites
qui avait été repoussée ça c'est aussi
un dossier que qui est suivi avec
attention vous êtes contre cette réforme
des retraites ah bah oui alors
aujourd'hui en tant qu' en tant que
cheminot de toute façon jamais battu
suppression des régimes spéciaux voilà
c'est ça on l'a on l'a largement
combattue au début d'année et on sera
encore dans la rue pour continuer parce
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui la vraie
solution ce serait réellement de
répartir le travail entre tous c'est
complètement aberrant de voir dans les
ateliers dans les usines les gens qui
crèvent au boulot ceux qui ont un
travail et épis à côté à côté de ça on
laisse des dizaines des centaines de
milliers de gens des millions de gens
sans travail sans rien
j'ai été alors que alors que bien sûr
qu'il ya du boulot dans les hôpitaux
dans les écoles
aujourd'hui il faudra embaucher
massivement sur cette thématique de
l'emploi si on voit plus large en termes
de politique de la ville c'est une
circonscription qui est totalement
dédiée à cette politique de la ville il
faut il faut faire davantage aujourd'hui
moi j'ai pas de jets pas de davie en
tout cas sur une politique de la ville
particulière comme moi y est les
quelques mois de l'exercice de nadia
dans cette circonscription
le problème c'est que c'est comme ce
qu'on a pu dire aux municipales c'est
que de toute façon il peut pas y avoir
un paradis peut pas y avoir une
circonscription où un îlot de de
bien-être pour les travailleurs pour les
salariés dans un monde où la crise et
est roi est bon est il vrai problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'effectivement les
travailleurs ne prennent pas conscience
et c'est ça le sens de ma candidature
c'est aussi de de dd à ce qu'ils
prennent conscience dans leur force
collective à la fois pour remplacer pour
remplacer la bourgeoisie à la tête de la
société parce qu'elle est effectivement
il faudra se poser le problème de
remplacer cette classe capitaliste qui
nous mène à la ruine aussi bien aussi
bien en france que dans le reste du
monde un dernier mot sur votre campagne
vous avez suivi lors d'une opération sur
le marché de trappes c'est pas trop
difficile en ce moment avec ce contexte
sanitaire d'aller à la rencontre des
électeurs
bah vous paradoxalement non les gens
sont plutôt contents de nous voir
contente de ce qu'on peut raconter
on a retrouvé des tas de gens qu'on
avait rencontré pendant la campagne des
municipales
d'ailleurs on va on va continuer à les
réunir ont fait un meeting
enfin une réunion publique par un
meeting mais en tout cas une réunion
publique le vendredi 18 à trappes à la
maison des familles
oui et tous les gens qui qu'on rencontre
aujourd'hui sur les marchés ou dans les
halls d'immeubles sont très contents de
nous voir et discuter de la situation
merci patrick plante je rappelle que
vous êtes le candidat de lutte ouvrière
pour cette législative partielle dans la
12e circonscription des yvelines